[Musique]
deux nouvelles sondes américaine une
européenne des projets russes indiens et
même une mission financée par rocket lab
une compagnie privée
en quelques mois la planète vénus est
devenu la nouvelle coqueluche de
l'astronomie et depuis à peu près un an
toute la communauté a vraiment tourner
son regard vers vénus et on se demande
est ce qu'il ya de la vie maintenant sur
vénus on veut connaître l'histoire de
vénus et en connaissant l'histoire de
vénus on va peut-être pouvoir connaître
un peu plus le feu le futur de la
planète terre plusieurs missions ont
étudié et cartographier cette planète
depuis les années 60 mais seuls les
russes ont réussi à se poser sur son sol
à prendre des relevés des photos et même
du son provenant de la surface
tout ça dans des conditions infernales
sur vénus il fait 465 degrés celsius et
la pression atmosphérique et de 93 bas
soit l'équivalent de plus de 900 mètres
de profondeur sous l'océan s'est vu
râler sont venus quand on pense à à mars
mars mars on a des astros mobiles qui
sont là depuis des jours des mois tout
ensemble avec des années sur vénus qu'on
envoie une sonde à la surface de vénus
elle peut servir seulement quelques
heures
l'émission près par la nasa et l'agencé
européenne sont complémentaires
elles vont entre autres cartographie
avec une grande précision la surface
agitée de vénus qui pourraient soutenir
unis dans ses activités volcaniques
on s'aperçoit que c'est une planète qui
a une géologie très complexe et qui
possiblement possède une tectonique très
très diverses est très varié avec des
des structures qui n'existe pas ailleurs
dans le système solaire
les chercheurs ont également étudié
l'épaisse couche de nuage qui recouvre
la planète
résultat d'un effet de serre format
géant ensuite ils vont tenter de tracer
un parallèle avec ce qui se passe
présentement sur terre on essaye de
comprendre comment cette planète la a pu
passer aussi rapidement d'un état où
elle pouvait posséder à l'origine de
l'oxygène en plus grande quantité a
maintenant une atmosphère qui semble
très fin qui est impossible pour la vie
mais ce qui fascine le plus c'est la
découverte récente et controversée de
gaz
la phosphine dans l'épaisse couche de
nuage qui recouvre venus là où il ya de
la phosphine il pourrait y avoir de la
vie
on pense qu'à peu près 50 km
au dessus de la surface il pourrait y
avoir de la vie
on parle de vie microbienne et c'est
vraiment de notre vie tout petit et ça
c'est dû à cette des couvertures de la
phosphine une découverte qui était fait
à peu près un an la compagnie raquette
la basse que ces missions vénusienne
sera prête en 2023
la nasa vise plutôt la fin de la
décennie ici normand grondin reste au
canada montréal